I've treated a lot of friends or
connections of people and we're trying
to climb Everest or in the in Nepal and
I can't tell how many of them were
expressing their love of Facebook after
finding out that their loved ones were
okay or in some cases not that's how I
found out about the earthquake in
general I woke up and I had a
notification saying that my friend Jenny
was safe she was in the region she was
about to hike in Kathmandu and this is
one of the ways that Facebook is trying
to make itself so essential this was
released after the earthquake and
tsunami in Japan in Facebook has been
releasing it after all these big
disasters how does it work it works so
Facebook if they see that you're in the
radius of the disaster they will send
you a ping saying you are you okay click
on this and tell us if you are and it'll
send a notification to all of your
friends and let them know and if you if
you look at the there's a there's a
counter that shows you here are the
friends that said they're safe here are
the people who haven't responded yet and
there's also some have fundraising
happening instantly on Facebook and
elsewhere talk about what Facebook is
doing first well Facebook is agreeing to
match donations up to two million
dollars so they're gonna have
notifications so users saying if you
donate we'll match it Google the people
finding effort which you mentioned it's
a little different it'll tell you if
other people have heard information
because it can't always be the person
who is in the situation who can say
something